i get the impression women go crazy for
simon cowell
it's kind of crazy when i the reason i
the way that i
met simon was they asked me to be a
guest judge focus
conan to be um
a lot of women worry about one breast
being smaller than the other
but focus on the positive one of them
it's bigger
and we call that one our favorite
i don't have all the answers
i don't have a big closer
[Music]
and i may not have a point
but i have a ten [__] joke and i'm gonna
use it right now like a lifeline
sit back relax and enjoy
hey so i told my girlfriend i wanted to
[__] her between the tits
she said how you gonna make that feel
good for me
i said right before i come i'll stop
punching you in the
face
don't you feel better now a good tit
[__] joke brings
people together as one race the human
race
when i was looking at pictures of my mom
when she was younger
please though so yeah please don't
cause i seen them pictures i'm kidding
i'm kidding not only is my mom
fine like my dad got a joy
and my dad was handsome too i'm not
gonna lie he was a little stuck
muffin so he was gonna start muffin
y'all worried
and right after i was born my mom had
the heavy pits
like when you look at your parents it's
just love can you look at her then
because
i need to confirm what i'm saying do it
that's the [__] she had the juggernaut
she had the juggernauts dude
she did oh gosh then sweater pups and
they were like
[Music]
and then i started looking at her and i
was like yo does my girl kind of look
like my mom a little bit back in the day
i might have an edible complex is it
autopilot
[__] my mom was looking edible
[Laughter]
let's go dad let's go dad
yeah i mean she just had damage joggers
you know how cow's got udders
i'm trying to get in on this yo this is
our mom goddamn
juggers bro you don't gotta say our mom
yeah wow
real talk you know you're saying you
don't look at pictures of your mom back
in the day
and you're just like this you're like
you already you you already sucked on
your mom's teeth
it's kind of funny when he's not saying
it to you it's kind of funny
son let's hang up on that so listen no
no no
back in the day when you were sucking on
your mom's tits
which you did do that's a fact that's a
fact of life
oh you were you're you're on the bottom
ain't no puerto rican having formula yo
son i love formula you were not on
formula i was on formula um
i don't know but there was formula
ovaltine
ovaltine in a chocolate milk yeah
that's not formula eddie knows about
formula
for real what when you were sucking on
your mom's teeth i didn't suck at my
mom's teeth
after y'all finished sucking did y'all
do this at the end like
did you do that a little bit did you
just
right when you finished baby
i probably did you said
now you're on board because how gosh on
the board because
after something delicious you go oh
is that what you're saying son you're
saying your mom's taste tastes delicious
bro
the milk was delicious you ever wiped
your mouth and then burping
[Music]
yeah you ever hold the titty in your
mouth and then burp into it to make it
bigger
[Music]
overrated underrated oh let's do that
those are fun this is me ignoring you
oh because you don't you don't get to
chime in overrated underrate overrated
wet t-shirt competitions
for some reason the fact that you can
kind of see a woman's titty through a
soaking wet t-shirt
seems to cause us men to flock by the
hundreds just to come
see never mind the women in that
situation
[__] like that really cheapens us as a
sex
uh why not just go out to a titty bar
like a real man
plus a titty dancer has more dignity at
least she's making good money out out of
the consequences of her [__] up
childhood
the rest of them are freezing their tits
off in a field in front of
some seedy old [__] with a hose
oh i see cdl festive guy spraying their
titties overrated
chicks with big boobs usually usually
they have back problems complain when
you
when you tweak their nips and are
generally thicker
harder to toss around what give me a b
cup skinny spinner any day of the week
built for speed
how is somebody's back problems your
issue you douchebag
because they're gonna stay and what girl
likes you to tweak their nipples
hey fyi douche
it's annoying and it hurts when you
tweak nipples they're sensitive
you dumbass you can't tweak their
nipples i mean what the [__]
idiot all right so we know how media
feels on that one all right underrated
girls boobs is i take it on it's my
issue
you know go [__] yourself this is
another woman's body
and it's underrated or overrated girls
with big boobs are
overrated i mean you know how it affects
me
you dumbass those boobs fed you
for probably longer than you needed to
you little mama's boy
now you have a boob complex
let me tell you something else about a
woman's body that i know nothing about
you know what sit down somewhere play
with your micro inch penis
that really annoyed me jesus christ
what did i tweak your nipple or
something recently you really went off
um all right give me a b
cup skinny girl any day ugh
that i actually you know i love the the
b cups the best
and see if you're going like long term
those those other ones are just going to
be [__] sitting in her lap
after a while and she's want to get want
to get a boob reduction
bill shut your [__] mouth what
you know nothing i know nothing you know
nothing
really those big ones don't end up
[__] hanging below your knees
they all end up getting saggy yeah news
flash
most women of a certain age if they
appear perkier than whatever they're
wearing a bra because
gravity happens it happens to your
[__] pink sack
and it happens to boobs get over it
yeah but the big [__]
you think i'm looking forward to looking
at your 80 year old balls i'm not am i
criticizing your titties
am i criticizing your titties no you're
not but i'm just you know
i'm gonna i don't give a [__] how much
you trash me i know i'm a mess
those big titties end up
down in your [__] lap they have a
shelf life to them they do and if they
that those broads go to sleep without a
bra on forget about it they're hanging
off the side of the bed
like you drooled off your pillow